well you're very close my friend
Alex Jones finally addressed Owen
Benjamin
oh yes he did today this is oh this is
fresh from today oh this is fresh from
today oh no so here we go
care about this country
you don't understand the threat to this
nation
now if you go to some leftist church or
some left a synagogue or some leftist
mosque you're gonna find the scum of the
earth that hate this country
and hate the family and hate God who've
captured churches
who've captured churches and synagogues
to tell us there is no God the goddamn
pain God is dead because oh yeah he
needs his papers it's unbelievable how
much paper is on that desk and he is
winding up and he has a Gabe Hoffman
level fire hazard going on in his Studio
sorry but I didn't mean it all right
they want to be God
so it's just not reality-based
and so I challenge people out there that
attack me and I'm not responding to you
because your attacks hurt me I'm
responding because I know a lot of you
are just
in your own form of group psychosis
group think
and you really attribute magical powers
to like their leprechauns or something
and but you you attack me because that's
the popular algorithm that the left
allows online you got some anti-semitic
Alex Jones rant baby Google green lights
you all the way
you've got some Unity situation like I
promote Google banjo-ash they don't want
Unity I'm really trying to make things
work here but remember
the Owen Benjamins of the world talented
comedian nice guy I had on because I
found out he was saying Germany had a
great leader in the early 40s
oh [ __ ] wow
it was a psychotic demon both my
grandfathers almost died fighting him
and they saw the dead bodies they saw
the piles of dead people don't give me
that crap yeah there was a lot of dead
bodies but it was mostly Russians but
Alex you also you also oversimplifying
uh Adolf as a quote psychotic demon also
yep uh uh puts the world in danger of
having another come about yeah you can't
dismiss things well they're just evil
people you if you can't understand
how a man can lead a nation to that
point
then it's then it could happen again
that's all I'm saying so I hate when
people go for evil demon people you're
like there were there were like [ __ ]
uh haberdashers and and uh shoe
repairmen that were [ __ ] members of
the party it didn't it wasn't demon
people uh so I I don't know I I hate
when people do that because it's like
all right you're gonna
if you want to get another uh that's how
you get another yep by going well at
least we're good people at least we're
using authoritarianism to impose good
happy fun time rainbow laws and that's
good and you're like oh no that's gonna
you're still doing
it's running on good time happy rainbow
times
to defend Owen for a little bit which is
actually way worse than defending him to
defend Owen for a little bit
was a good leader if you were German
no am I wrong no no am I saying
something's wrong
German people were prosperous for a
while for a minute for a bit I'm not
saying forever I'm not saying forever if
they if he didn't get too big for his
britches to decide I gotta get into
Russia we've been able to live living in
a different planet right now
and those I gotta say I disavow uh what
what me Lopez and I will not uh I will
not uh be Associated or affiliated with
this denying uh
far-right terrorism
oh [ __ ] sorry Alex
that I'm censoring or I sold out no dude
you're on YouTube I'm not I'm under
attack and banned everywhere they've
taken my bank accounts away they're
trying to shut us down right now I've
been sued 20 something times I'm on the
front lines I'm changing the world and
our audience is
and people like oh and sit there and say
oh you know Trump's great but oh Jones
is a sellout to Israel no go after Trump
then that you don't have the huevos
because the yeah now now to go on Owen
for a second to say
Alec Trump is great but Alex Jones is
sold out to Israel maybe he has but to
pretend that Trump has not already all
up Israel's ass 100 [ __ ] I wait
until you see my statue in Golan Heights
it's going to be unbelievable it's going
to be the tallest statue in the history
of Israel it's going to be taller than
their wall
so which we pay for so the oppressed
people of Palestine can see my face
poking over the wall disapproving of
them
he'll be scowling in the Statue yes
Golden Heights will be I'm sorry Trump
Heights Scoopy
the greatest neighborhood in the history
of the Middle East
oh man
wait till they fix the Trump strip uh
all of Dane we better go save George
while we can Owen's gonna lose his [ __ ]
over this oh he is
any semites won't do it and I'm sorry
you're Jewish you don't like your dad
Owen that was sorry you got Daddy Issues
bro daddy issues with my dad
I love my daddy that's right my dad was
a real man tough man fought in the wars
I don't know which ones but he fought in
some Wars please do my favorite the hell
if you don't know at all there it is my
God I love it if you want to come on
down to Texas boy get beat up by five
foot ten Texas boy
and possible CIA asset
but definitely the Texas thing yeah
definitely the Texas part red-blooded
American you never told me hey I'm
English and Irish and Scottish and
American Indian that's who we are he
brought me up that we're Americans we
believe in Freedom
and that's what it came down to please
don't forget we're only here because of
your support okay and that's
that's into a live read
uh you hear that you tall son of a [ __ ]
come on down the taxi town you know oh
oh man remember when he was in love with
Alex Jones not even a month ago and
everything his everything he loves is
falling apart he's he is isolated man
come on come on Owen two more days